I feel like um I saw Kim Kardashian like
walking somewhere I came or she was
walking and her hair was like behind her
and she had this posture and I was like
that's just exactly what you've been
doing wait really yeah you've been just
it's nice on a posture of a Kardashian
that's the best compliment I've ever
received yeah I live in a fantasy where
I'm a Kardashian
which what's your birth order wait what
do you mean like where are you are you a
Courtney who's like the oldest and you
know I think okay I'm not the oldest but
I do feel a combo of Courtney and Kim
what about
um
you're nothing but he is a
you're right nothing what are you Kim is
obviously the best but Courtney is the
same height as me which is so good guys
I don't want to say it but I feel like
my shoulders have I don't want to be but
I'm Chloe wait no I'm Chloe you're Chloe
the width of my shoulders alone beats
the women you're Rob I'll be Rob I'm
Blac Chyna oh no that is the best role I
take it back that's the best one I'm
Blac Chyna's mom
this show is sponsored by better help
get a break from your thoughts with
better help visit betterhelp.com trash
Tuesday today to get 10 off your first
month that's betterhelp help.com trash
Tuesday stop wasting money on things you
don't use Esther cancel your unwanted
subscriptions kalila and manage your
money the easy way by going to
rocketmoney.com trash Tuesday that's
rocketmoney.com trash Tuesday
rocketmoney.com trash Tuesday thank you
to our sponsor price picks go to
pricepix.com trash Tuesday and use code
trash Tuesday for a first deposit match
up to a hundred dollars that's
pricepix.com trash Tuesday and use code
trash Tuesday for a first deposit match
up to a hundred dollars price picks its
daily fantasy sports made easy
it's not the best part I'm stormy I want
to be dream okay well let's talk to the
audience for a second I'm sorry welcome
to our show things are a little
different around here
does someone else want us welcome to
blood bathroom not yet the Revival maybe
though we're working on it we think our
new producer's ex-husband is a lawyer
and so we think that's going to help us
we think maybe we can use some of the
money he took from her
and be like can we use this you know
um we have a brand new set and we
actually made the first huge change
since we've been doing this show we have
a whole new team of producers
um it was just kind of time for some
fresh meat baby's blood Juicy Girl meat
and we have female producers who are
awesome that we met when they were
helping us produce our live show and we
just all clicked and it was kind of time
for a change and so
here we are yeah I feel like our posture
is better I feel like where's washer is
you're so good right now which is like
looks like you got a new set if you know
what I mean
should I though no what
don't do a boob job but you know how
like the whole thing now is
um micro implants really so yeah before
I don't think they used to make um
implants that were smaller than like 300
CC's or something can I see micro
implants before and after
but the look is basically the Olivia
Rodrigo look which is the you can tell I
don't know I'm not going to speak to
whether or not she's got anything done
but it is the the micro boobs you know
that is definitely oh no Esther how did
you get your pictures up there okay
those are braces
um which I also incidentally a person
incidentally I want bracelet micro
braces
um so it's a very tiny enhancement I
think they're like 200 CC's you're maybe
getting up to like a you know a full B
this is real like I know people who have
done this and I think it's kind of
awesome and I'm my whole life have
always been like I want breast implants
I love yes ever since I was little I
prayed for boobs I was like if I don't
get the ones I want I'm gonna get
implants and like up until literally you
got one that you like yeah they're you
know they have really oh they're great
they're fraternal isn't that what we say
um
one's Annie and one's Max that's her
twin brother that doesn't call her back
um but up until this past year there has
been so much news about implant breast
implant illness like it's now its own
illness do you know this yeah it's well
before it used to just be like anecdotal
right like girls like me would say hey
I'm taking my implants out because I
have X Y and Z happening to me and it
really only happened after my implants
um but I think more and more you know
research is going into it and I do think
like there's a foreign body going into
you like it can only trigger some weird
[__] like a bacterial infection I mean
not for everybody because I mean my
sister has you know I have friends who
have implants and with zero
complications but for me immediately I
felt different immediately everything
about me including my mood including my
anxiety I also didn't even like them
right no because I had asked for full
C's and I woke up with
that is that doctor was horny and you
know what he said right he said
basically because my my breasts are
further set apart that if he didn't put
bigger implants I wouldn't really have a
full cleavage
but I'm like wait but maybe I didn't
want a full like also a squishful
cleavage is weird like when it's like
you're not touching it and there's
cleavage like that you meant yeah I
still can't believe that day when I met
you when you had your implants in you
wouldn't show them to me because I
didn't like them she I've never seen
your tits and it's infuriating
10 seconds she pulled mine up mine were
out I'll I'll text them to you right now
can you just grade my tits I'm gonna
text them to you but do you so you
actually felt physically sick as well
that's when my heart stuff started
happening that's when a lot of like
weird autoimmune stuff started happening
for me I started getting like I started
[__] blood like all the weird stuff
happened this is actually really
affecting the trajectory of my life
because my whole life I've I feel a lot
of confidence from my breasts right I
love them they're great they're I've
always loved breasts I was breastfed
until I was three and a half like I just
have this really you know I always tell
like Rick last or any guy like if you
got breast implants like I would be
attracted to you yeah
um but now and so I've always felt like
okay obviously I'm gonna get older like
one day I might have a kid but I will
always be able to fix them because
that's the magic of like science that
men created for us but now I'm like I
will not be sick for the price of looks
yeah so what do
now what
Annie what's it like to be sick for the
price of love to have these big fake
boobs I don't know I like my fake boobs
I think uh no I actually do have huge
boobs randomly did you get micro is that
what we're talking about this
you just eat more you eat more wait did
you get my text I sent you my tits
guys I love this hook but this is a
cheat because I am laying down and this
is this is this is not the fake boobs
right no this is my current boobs but I
have gotten around I wait I waited for
them to get really hard and dark it
looks like you don't have an arm I can't
believe you don't show these off
those are the best
look that when I'm standing they don't
look that great I'm looking at that bald
beef her body that's like I don't want
to talk about it anymore because it's
not fair to the viewers
that's
but they're okay right it's okay you can
have they're just you can have anything
you want in this world I want you to
know she knows don't you know a little
bit a little bit yeah you guys I've been
convinced yeah
but would you think you would ever you
would never get implants again right
there I'll be as honest as possible
there are times when I look at my body
and I'm like oh [__] like they're it's
not that my because I only had implants
for a year and a half so there wasn't a
whole lot of stretch
what I just got this picture along with
hers and then my nipples was like out
wait who sent you that Troy Conrad yes
right that's out
let me see
like he's blind I why are all my
photographers Blind by the way every
photographer I have is like they're like
looking at the pictures like I think
this one's good you know that
Seinfeld where Elaine gets a photo shoot
and then it's everyone's like oh I see
your nipple it's like it that is
violating my old tits out
um so when I'm standing fully naked in
the mirror my thoughts are this I'm like
I look great I feel strong tits are a
little weird those are my three thoughts
every time I look in the mirror and
that's because was it before boob job
too or
um no after boob job it's not even that
it's true that they're weird it's just
that you you've done something to your
body that you cannot undo and there is
sort of this feeling of betrayal where
I'm like I have why did I do this so
there's a sadness there where I'm like
oh I feel like I mutilated myself and I
think that how I feel about about myself
filters through that's this thing I did
and even though every guy yeah through
the nipple and every guy I've been with
is like no your boobs are just fine but
I cannot get it out of my head that I've
mutilated they don't say just fine they
say it's okay you know I don't know
they're okay they're mid Kylie Jenner
was having this same conversation on the
Kardashians she was like I had great
boobs I don't know why I did this I
think this is a common thing
um and you are right to bring this up
because I did just read something that
breast implants are like still thriving
like they're oh more than ever yeah it's
like more popular with Gen Z and also
the young girls are so like open about
it like the influencers like just got my
boobs done I feel like in our day it was
like secret I know but they weren't but
they were like they're so obvious yeah
because they were so back then they were
very high profile very tight up top like
that was the look of like the 90s right
the the very tight titties mine are
uneven so when I look in the mirror I
just like kind to like pull one shoulder
back and then like and then I'm like oh
I look good and then the chin does that
and then it you know you're like oh this
is perfect and like they're amazing Dave
come look what are the three would the
dog like come look look at the dog yeah
when you stand in front of a mirror
completely naked what are the first
three thoughts that come to mind okay
the first is obviously the boob
unevenness okay
the stomach is just never
it's just never gonna be
what your dream is am I wrong no you are
wrong what you're wrong there are days
where I'm like I my stomach is
incredible
Annie I look listen I'm like delusional
so if I work out one time I'm like I'm
the hottest girl in L.A I can't believe
it I'm ripped it's like I see the
journey I'm like Oh my God in like six
weeks like watch out and then I
completely stop working out again
but um
I've been doing a thing where I just buy
baggier clothes yes and everyone goes oh
my God skinny queen I'm like yeah wait
that is such a hack I do the same thing
you just buy like yeah you go oh god oh
these used to fit
um and I knew it with shirts too yeah
they have to be double XL or bust
what do you what do you guys do you have
insecurities when if you look at like
full naked body of yourself
if I have a spray tan you can't hurt me
if I don't have a spray tan I don't know
it just depends I'm always like all
right I want to work out more or
whatever I'm always in the process I'm
always like looking at my before picture
going like with a lot of Grace going oh
I can't wait till
I start working out every day so you
just called yourself in the mirror your
before picture yeah oh my God this is
gonna be so cute no I don't know I told
you guys when I was in yoga and I had
the realization where I was like oh I
have to just like love myself no matter
what
duh
yeah no but like really like that's like
adjusting and stuff I have to just that
is the whole it has nothing to do with
how I look that is the whole idea behind
we know that I know that that just
because they're a little hand away I
can't
that's the whole idea behind Rat Girl
Summer like rat girl summer is just full
acceptance eat everything
um there is no embarrassment
um show off your thick arms like the
whole idea is just like full acceptance
and how old are we with rock girl I'm
having a rat girl summer I actually
think I didn't realize till now but I am
definitely having no you're a rat face
summer I have Rat Life somewhere
um you like being in basements you
nibble food
yes also I'm not doing my nails anymore
I literally didn't even show up with
makeup today I'm like I just don't have
the energy like I don't care wait you
took your jewelry off too that I can't
explain I don't know what I think I was
traveling no because I did the same
thing yesterday I just got so sick of
everything that I tore it off my body
I'm like I just need my nails to be
unpolished I need my body to be bare and
I had this feeling like I need to just
be absolutely naked off everything but
then I see Annie and she is never been
more jeweled up I just got more I
haven't been wearing earrings for a
while I got no Hoops I went to the mall
and I shop shop wait talk to me about
the snake necklace snake necklace well
now I'm the mother of reptiles we have
two snakes since last we spoke
two new ones there's one that has a pug
face I don't know what it's called I
think it's a pug no snake I want that
too
so I'm a mother of snakes then an ankh I
always see when I do Ayahuasca I don't
really know what it is Egyptian where's
the snake necklace from it's all from
the same place I can't remember what
it's called child of something
hmm child or something but then and then
this is 555 for this is for Vanessa my
soon-to-be mother-in-law how cute is the
Hognose snake
is that it wait you gotta show oh wait
that is cute wait where's his face
right there how cute is that so cute
dude my favorite thing is when I'm
walking around like my neighborhood or
like the yard people think you're a pug
that is also my favorite thing but when
I see lizards
when I see little [__] reptiles I
just get so giddy and yesterday I saw
the cutest baby one like I love do you
see them in La yeah I do it's such a
treat I'm like we could catch I see them
in Todd's room a lot there's literally a
thousand now it's every time I go to
town he gets a new reptile do you make
love in front of lizards they're they
watch they're interested no Randy we
have to like Randy's so annoying he's
such a [__] block problem
no he even like when Todd comes to kiss
me ready like it's like we're trying to
take his food exactly oh wait a second I
want to talk about this I truly think he
doesn't like our love no it's this is a
real thing I want to discuss because I
think that you know how they say like oh
children get in the way of your sex life
my animals got in the way of my sex life
yeah you have to like and then they're
whining outside they do not like when
they used to hate it when Bobby and I
would even come close to each other they
would intervene and they hated they'd
start barking really loud so we couldn't
have them in our bedroom because they
would just what does donut look like
they have no issues donut is like there
on the corner of the bed just like
zoning out pretending she's leaving her
body but she's pretending to like be
okay sometimes though we'll be like
let's just leave her in the living room
but it is hard for us and also sometimes
like shh
this is making me laugh so hard like
we'll be like going getting into it and
then she'll just like walk up to us and
start like licking one of us and it
kills me like I because we're both so
desperate for that love for her that
like I can't turn her away I'm like Dave
like please hold on and he's like he
gets so mad at me but it's so cute it's
like forced edging
but I can't believe your dog your dog
you're one I understand seven animals
but you're one dog no it's so annoying
but they all hate the love all seven of
my animals he wants to be like on like
Randy wants to be like here on me at all
times
which is so exciting he loves me and
wait I have to tell you about this
necklace because it's very cute what I
did so it's five five and in Laos ha is
five so it's hahaha and Laos oh I like
that it's like you that's super cute I
got it for Vanessa my woody
mother-in-law what do you guys think of
couples taking MDMA together to save
their relationship
doesn't sound great it's like this new
thing of like couples therapy where they
add either a long time yeah I think but
it's more mainstream now I think before
people would just do it on their own but
now they have like assisted ones that
couples do and apparently it's sort of
like if you're stuck somewhere in your
relationship like some people describe
it as like I never knew him or I never
knew her until now sounds fun I want to
do it I do too we should do it the three
of us together
that's your best bet I've never done
MDMA so we have to ask Annie like why
does this make sense I don't is MDMA is
like what is it it's not Molly Molly oh
let's definitely do it
guys are you serious we our fourth cast
member should be named Molly
should be here all the time does it make
sense to you though that this could save
relationships it just yeah you just feel
good you're happy does it unlock
something sexually about you yeah you're
like horny the wind blows but you can't
even have sex on Molly right or can you
or should you you can I mean I guess
people say you shouldn't because you'll
be too like who have you done it with
uh sex not Molly
well do we have a while mother I'm so
sick of this like high value woman thing
now that's out wait explain it yeah
because we were they all wanted to be
[__] and now they're like whoa whoa
whoa is your count over two I'm like
whoa whoa whoa you guys were tearing our
underwear off what the hell is going on
now now you want a high value one
[__] yourself I think a high value woman
I have a different
um description of a high value woman I
think a high value woman is someone
who's by the age of 35 has been married
twice
um someone with a body count of at least
45 and up
and someone who's just really really
um burned through rubber you know what I
mean like burn some rubber like actually
lived a lot like if you're under 20 like
I'm like did you have a life exactly did
you have under 20 years old or no under
20 count oh [__]
don't
try to pretend I am definitely not under
20. I'm definitely under then you're 19.
what
you guys
Annie look at me
I don't think there's I have no judgment
like I I have judgment on you yeah
I'm wearing glasses I'm not hiding it
and I know that more than 20 men have
[__] this is not true under 20. huh
like I could go under another we could
go under a bigger a smaller number don't
say 10.
oh
I want let's talk back to talking about
high value women because I do agree with
you that it's not about body count at
all and it's just about how you carry
yourself
and also I know that you just threw in
twice divorce because you just found out
our new producer has or she's been
married twice when when Stella says I'm
on my second marriage I'm like oh I
respect you infinitely more like I feel
like I love so much more wisdom
no but also you said you like you made a
promise in front of all your loved ones
and then you were like nah
getting proposed to is not caring and
just being like I just didn't care at
all about getting proposed to with
either of them and then they were like
oh this is a challenge I have to really
I wish I had met you 10 years ago yeah
it's not it wasn't easy mine backfired
playing cool girl backfired yeah I was
like oh I don't care about marriage and
they were like okay cool neither do I
yeah I think it depends on the guy but I
just really always said I was like do
not propose to me like I would have lost
my mind if any of the guys I did it
proposed to me or if Todd had proposed
to me before we started talking about it
I would have it would have ended I don't
think I would have stayed with them
but okay so hear me out so I was talking
to my friend Sawyer who you know through
Stella oh yeah Barry who's on our show
and basically we were like wait a second
like that is something I think that I
want one shitty elopement under my belt
before I turned 40 I want some weird
Reckless thing
and I think that is that
because I never did drugs right and it's
like I'm feeling a little bit oh my God
I did get married wait a second oh no
what I did get married on Molly I got
married on ecstasy to Mark Medina my
Mexican boyfriend [__] Marky we got
married we had a whole ceremony my
friend had been ordained and so we're
all [__] up
is he like gonna come at you for half
your mind we didn't sign it you have to
sign something okay Imagine by next week
you have to start paying alimony
[Laughter]
I know what you're making did I tell you
that I like reconnected I think I told
you I was this because he was the one
that was like
he came back to me like years later and
was like I feel so I had to go to like
this Chinese medicine doctor to deal
with all my PR and I like I realized how
much I hurt you and I was like oh I was
like not in love with you yeah relax
buddy I was like we're bud and then we
were like hanging out again and he we
made out there was like a Vibe one night
and we made up but he had his Invisalign
on still he's like so disrespectful to
have like a it was so like Smooth I mean
I was like oh is your Invisalign wait
this is the real question I have so
because I'm thinking about getting
Invisalign oh I love your teeth no I
don't want to close the gaps so
apparently I need to separate the
bottoms a little bit because my bite is
causing me TMG TMJ pain so it's not
about that I did I did Invisalign for my
uh
overbite and it helped a lot so
basically what she said it helps a lot
yeah it was a lot worse Dr Yamada
basically said this she was like we
don't need to close the gaps completely
she's like I agree like keep your teeth
are super cute but we need to kind of
fix your bite a little bit better so I
agreed to it but here's the thing like
how often do I have to wear it should I
make out in my
invisaligned
I only slept in you yeah which is not
that good you're not supposed to but
dude my Pilates teacher will like
literally show up to class on the mic in
her Invisalign I'm like you don't need
it right now you don't need to have it
well you remember when I had the the
thing for a second for my TMJ the the
night guard yeah and then no I had a day
guard and the guy was like he was like
he was like
you don't have a list when I was like I
have a lift and he was like you know I
was like and I was like I talk for a
living and he's like you're fine you're
fine and he was like you cannot take
this off there was one I had to wear
during the day and when I just never I
just wasted five thousand dollars well
if I get invisaligns they have to put
those little Nubs on my teeth I had
those they're horrible okay so that's
another thing it's like I can't have
that and be single right like I won't
catch a dick for years you're not wrong
I love it you're not wrong it's I was so
insecure when I had those Nubs on but
you have big lips that kind of might
hide them yeah I forgot what they're not
what I smile or or Oh you mean even when
I'm talking yeah they'll think you're
like birding because you won't be
smiling no it looks like you have like a
chunk of food stuck to your tooth you
guys you know what I want to do I want
to do a palette expander why so I can
rest my tongue better because all of my
TMJ and everything I have is because my
I don't have the right tongue posture
I've been working on it I've been like
having my tongue down you're supposed to
have your tongue down up on your roof
and as a kid you're supposed to not
sleep with your mouth open because
um
you don't develop like a wide enough
um but when they do these palette
expanders you get a huge gap for my like
really bad it's like a true size Gap
you're gonna look like Michael Strahan
it's a Michael Strand it's like a big
one
[Music]
sponsored by betterhelp
um I would love nothing more than a
break from my own thoughts I'm just
gonna keep it real
I we have mhd it's mental health days
are a big part of my life they happen to
me whether I want them to or not it's
inevitable and I use therapy as a way to
get through my days especially the ones
where I can't get out of bed and if
you're thinking of starting therapy give
better help a try I wish they had better
help when I was in high school and I
found out that my best friend was dating
my boyfriend yeah it was just 17 kids in
my class so it was like you couldn't
really everyone so I just was at home
depressed getting tutored
which by the way better help is like
getting tutored in therapy I think it's
a great place to start it's entirely
online it's designed to be convenient
flexible and suited to your schedule
just fill out a brief questionnaire to
get matched with a licensed therapist
and the best part is you can switch
therapists you can hang up on them I
really like you bye exactly and you can
switch your switch therapist for no
additional charge which is such a
difficult thing to do usually when it's
not set up this way also I've had
therapists that are looking a little low
a little low when you're sitting in that
chair okay
better help it's a neck up baby
get a break from your thoughts with
better help that sounds nice visit
betterhelp.com trash Tuesday today to
get 10 off your first month that's
better help help.com trash Tuesday
rocket money is a personal finance app
that finds and cancels your unwanted
subscriptions monitors your spending and
helps you lower your bills all in one
place and let me tell you boy did I need
this I didn't realize I had I had been
paying years for like an insect finder
app
I mean what to have you find your pets
my best friends guys that's the house
we're gonna find friends do you have any
is that your dating app no it's like
it's basically an app where you identify
insects in your home I guess plant one
where you go that's an important one to
have I don't use it you don't I have
Todd he's the plant finder do you have
any apps like that are reptile related
for you no I don't have that yet but I
will say that I downloaded an app and
subscribed to a service where my phone
could be my garage key and then I
realized that it didn't have the right
serial number on it so I just am paying
to not to still lose my garage key and
my phone does not work as it rocket
money can even negotiate to lower your
bills for you by up to 20 all you have
to do is take a picture of your bill and
Rocket money takes care of the rest we
all need this rocket money also lets you
monitor all your expenses in one place
recommends custom budgets based on your
past spending and they'll even send you
notifications when you've reached your
spending limits I don't know anyone in
my life who doesn't need this app I know
you don't want it sometimes and they
make it so difficult to cancel anything
that button is so hard to find and it's
all you scroll all the way you know what
I found out I was subscribed to the same
patreon twice
how is that possible it was your own
stop wasting money on things you don't
use for one dollar cancel your unwanted
subscriptions and manage your money the
easy way by going to rocketmoney.com
trash Tuesday that's rocketmoney.com
trash Tuesday rocketmoney.com trash
Tuesday
guys
I never fantasize about sports until
money got involved and now I gotta I get
it okay I'm usually sitting on the
sidelines chewing Todd on but the fact
that now I get to be a part of this with
prize picks is a bigger prize than I
could ever pick for myself you guys
price picks is the most fun I've had
winning 25 times my money this football
[Laughter]
is like my whole life guys when you when
I say foot she says ball okay
when you say foot I say no you can't see
them
you just select two or more players pick
more or less on their projected stats
and then place your entries it's so easy
they give you a hundred dollars you guys
this is crazy price picks is really
simple to play I can make my picks and
submit my entry in less than 60 seconds
it's quick withdrawals easy games
with price picks it's really quick
withdrawals easy gameplay and an
enormous selection of players and Stat
types I didn't know you were a New
Yorker
why it would roll I don't know how to
say that word
because my other option is withdrawals
listen they're all good keep going leave
this in hold on let me let me get that
right quick quick
withdrawals easy gameplay
quick withdrawals easy gameplay and an
enormous selection of players and Stat
types are what make price picks the
number one daily fantasy sports app do
you know that I want to put a hundred
dollar bet on you not being able to say
withdrawals Annie you can't bet on that
prize picks now offers Apple pay for
quick and easy deposits into your
account this football season we like
things that are quick and easy yes easy
easy take my money make me money let's
go go go go go go we have a winner
you guys know who I'm selecting this
week on prize picks
um Aaron Rodgers for more than three
passing touchdowns
did you know that Annie Justin he sounds
hot Odell Beckham Jr for more than 50
yards and Josh Allen for more than two
passing touch-ups for this Max Max where
are you
price picks offers weekly promotions
that can lead to Big payouts like taco
Tuesday each Tuesday price fixed
discounts select player projections up
to 25 to provide even more value price
picks now offers Apple pay for quick and
easy deposit or you already said that
that's a great Apple pay baby let's make
this simple saquan Barkley for more than
60 years one sequan and Patrick Mahomes
for more than two passing touchdowns go
to prizepix.com trash Tuesday and news
code trash Tuesday for our first deposit
match up to 100 that's prizepix.com
trash Tuesday and use code trash Tuesday
for a first deposit match up to 100
prize picks daily fantasy sports Made
Easy
back to the thing you said about a guy
came up to you was like I'm sorry I hurt
you and you were like I didn't care
about you it was my greatest Revenge why
is my instinct that if a guy did that
for I would literally like no matter
what the truth was I would milk it and
be like yeah you really hurt me and then
I could have gotten some sunglasses
dramatized it and like make him feel bad
just like see where we can make him feel
bad I think he would beat his ego
somehow and be like wow you could get
gifts out of it like what kind of gifts
well I don't okay so I had a boyfriend
who did [__] me over like he took money
from but he didn't steal money but we
went on a road trip he took money from
you no okay we went on a road trip for
spring break
my friend John I'm still friends with
him he's so crazy but we went on a trip
for spring break we I had had a
prospective student come visit me and
like she was looking at the college so
she stayed in my dorm with me and I like
took her around but I would just be like
should I cook I would like take them I'd
be like I'm gonna show you like wait
that's what recruit trips are for to
take drugs I almost died at Ohio State
on my recruiter I came back with like
bilateral pneumonia and I was in the
hospital for two weeks because I smoked
that much weed oh my God
I want them to like see what like is the
good part of the school which is like
the hang the party college is about like
learning social she's right and he's
right I think cocaine is you have to
offer that to your recruits do you like
Coke I can get you Coke what do you want
yeah I agree do you like MDMA do you
want to watch me get married Mexican
um he named himself doggy Marky don't
come for me or come for me it's cute
um but so okay so we went on this road
trip and we picked up my perspective
student she lived in um so we were in
Santa Fe and we went she lived in Napa
Valley so we drove up and then his
family has a a house in Oregon like a
Seaside like a beach house so we were
driving up there so we'd pick up
Madeleine the protect prospective
student and
um they start hooking up by the way Josh
has run out of money the money he
brought ran out like the second day so I
was like just putting it on my credit
card because there's we're already on
the trip it was my car so it was like
miles it's your responsibility to take
the student to the school we picked her
we hung out with her while she was there
and then we're like oh we'll pick
Madeline up we liked her
you're hanging out with her after oh
that's weird yeah that's so weird
in touch with your perspectives come
making friends have you ever done that
she couldn't Advance my career is that
why it was weird I think that that is an
abusive power did you end up going to
the school
no because it was weird because she
started like hooking up with my
boyfriend on the trip it was weird I was
like I would like come on the show I'm
like are you guys hooking up but I
didn't want to be
Josh like Josh had pulled the thing
where he was like I'm gonna stop being
friends with you I'm in love with you
like be my boyfriend I was like what I
don't want to be your boyfriend or your
girlfriend and he was like he was like
then we're not friends I was like oh all
right fine I'll be your girlfriend
because I just like wanted to hang out
with him and um
but yeah it was wild so then he um so
then he got me back I guess for not
wanting to be his girlfriend and then so
I wasn't mad at him either but he owed
me like he had just spent all like it
was like fifteen hundred dollars at the
end I mean you're in college you're like
I knew that money my parents are like
what the [__] is on your credit card
bill
and I was like oh so then my mom came
into town and I would call him and try
to trick him and uh because we stopped
being friends obviously because he
cheated on me in front of my face and
then we had to drive back and as we
stopped at his aunt's house and she gave
me um a cassette tape to listen it was
Angela's Ashes oh my God my favorite
book
s it's a great book but it was like so
depressing and followed up by two my
favorite books you listen to that on the
drive yes on the drive back after he had
cheated on it was like it's not exactly
road trip like energy
it's about it's like consumption in
Ireland yeah
yeah several children dying yeah not
having food and then having to like you
know what I mean eat salt and water for
dinner it's really sad I was crying I
was like I was like is it raining or is
this
it was a it was a rough trip it was fun
but it was rough and it was fun but
there were fun moments I don't know he's
like bipolar so he's fun you know
sometimes it was fun so like stuff was
happening but then he used to pick me up
from class he'd be like I'd come out of
uh he would know like my schedule and I
would just walk outside of class out of
the building and he'd be like the door
would be like get in my car we're going
to the hot springs and we'd like go to
the hot springs it'd be so fun but I'd
be like cold because I wasn't prepared
to go to the house okay I actually know
what you mean because I just this is
random but I just re-watched all the
Christopher Nolan Batman movies and Bane
my takeaway was like wait Bane is like
the best he would be the best boyfriend
because whenever he shows up on screen
you're like it's about to be so exciting
but um he so yeah so he um owed me money
for about 10 years
okay so he left Santa Fe and moved back
to Connecticut or whatever and I was
working at the Cowgirl Restaurant and he
walked out of the bathroom like he just
walked out of the bathroom and I went
Josh and he's like Annie he goes I owe
you money
yeah I go you do and he goes let's go
shopping
so he just like bought me sunglasses and
stuff he's bipolar he's the best oh so
fun it was so fun wait I have a similar
story to this
so he's still my friend I love him
there's this boy I dated when I was
really young and he was a lot older than
me but when I I dated him when I was
like 13 and then I she always takes it
to
I'm sorry it's always just like and it's
so she goes in so casual we know like we
know it's gonna happen he was much older
than you and you were 13 13. okay and he
used to woo Me by bringing like mangoes
like a box of mangoes to my family lip
smackers anyways I
um
I went back to the Philippines I had
been in the states for six years at this
point I went back to the Philippines
when I was 19 and he found out that I
was going back to the Philippines so
like we met up and he was like oh wow
you've really like grown up
and um he's like I'm so much less
attractive yeah he throws up I want he
wanted to hook up but then I wouldn't
put out because I was like at this point
I hadn't grown up and being like no like
not interested right remember when you
learned you could say no I learned like
three years ago oh no me too I'm like oh
my God I could have said no to all these
people I have her [__] count you know
what's crazy is I have my account I've
never had to say no
I've still never learned no I have never
had to use that so but this guy
um we um I I don't know for sure this is
all alleged but we think he drugged me
and I ended up in the hospital so you
did do MDMA possibly but I remember just
being so blacked out I had one drink and
one drink only and all of a sudden the
room started spinning and then I don't
remember much after that I ended up in
the hospital but I thankfully had
another friend there who saw that I had
I was going down but she did see this
guy try to take me back to his hotel
because we're all in this like Party
Island she did see him try to take me
back to his hotel room and she like you
know intervene was like hey what's wrong
with kalila she's like no she's coming
with me I gotta go grab her sister like
she doesn't look well ended up in the
hospital but so I think that there was
an attempt to drug me me because
um I didn't put out you know I didn't
put out when I was 13 and then I wasn't
gonna put out at 19. but hi again
because of would it be like he like
drugged you and they took you back and
he was like oh it's so old she's so old
no that is just you just barrel rolls
you out of the but
um there was a really really big apology
about everything that he had done like
maybe like five years after the facts
like she filled the time he denies that
he ever he's like no just trying to help
you like somebody else did that anyways
there's a really big apology and instead
of just being like you know what don't
ever speak to me again I did what Annie
did which was oh like maybe I he's like
I'll do anything I'll do anything for
you and I was like you know what I'm
actually planning this when I was I had
two boyfriends I was living with two
boys oh my God I was like I'm actually
planning a trip back home with like two
of my boyfriends he was like use my
Beach property you can stay there and I
was like property yeah and I was like
okay and I did and I had all the guys
that molested me were like not nope
I had to lend them money while they were
molesting me I also did not see the
beach property I'm really thrown but is
it Beach property I'm like he bribed you
with like mangoes and like and he had a
Beach property no no he was like he's
still he's like he was a wealthy guy but
yeah and I went with two of my
boyfriends to his Beach
Place why don't you take these
boyfriends and we had a really fun
vacation oh [__] a lot call them up be
like I'm still struggling from that
night I need one more trip to the beach
property
that's where we should do Molly we have
to do it together
that's so scary to me it's not you've
already done the other one wait I
actually have like a random two guy
story from it's but it's sad I know both
of them count it's there was no sex it's
from middle school well how many people
did you blow
it is less than what I've had sex with
what you guys that is so much more
intimate no than penis in the vagina
kissing is intimate you can't get
pregnant from
blows yeah blowies are for free there's
calories there are calories I put mine
in my MyFitnessPal come see me live I
have a really good joke about it okay so
in middle school I don't know why I
don't know if I've ever talked about
this on here like it's just coming up
because you were seeing two guys
whatever but like
there is these two both of them of
course like really heavy set Italian
Guys which was like my thing from like
sixth grade onward like the Harry middle
schooler like not even Harry actually
like light both of them had light hair
which I would like never be into now but
like light hair light eyes like heavy
like Jonah Hill you're describing me
heavier wait the eye is um but they were
best friends
and I was into both of them and like oh
for whatever reason like I think I like
basically data one then did another
whatever and then
um
I invited one of them this is so this is
you're about to punch me in the face I
invited one of them to go to
Art Plus
which is an after-school art program
because I was like the like I know I'm
so sorry I please just please so I
invite one of them to go with me
and then these two get together they
think they're gonna get one over on me
they both show up I'm like oh is that
how you guys want to play fine so the
I'm like you I'm making them sit through
we do like two hours whatever of an art
project
and I'm like oh my God I double down I'm
like What's the art project I don't
remember is it like putting your hand
prints down making turkeys with your
hands
snowman's with cotton balls there might
have been some
clay whatever we had an art art program
had a good budget
um
I'm like I double down I'm like why
don't you guys both come over
and so they both like literally got on
the school bus came over and like I made
them sit there and watch a movie with me
and I realized the story has no exciting
moment in it because I was in sixth
grade and there's like no hookup but I
did at least like I was like you guys
think you're gonna make me uncomfortable
by both of you being here like no I'm
gonna make it worse for you so you tried
your first MMF
in sixth grade which is kind of
amazing thank you
are you just no no and your first MFA
masters of Fine Arts
but nobody
came super cute nobody I mean in middle
school they come in their pants they're
not like no one's coming outside their
pants did you you said Dry home guys
till they came
um I used to that was my favorite you
know
I did that you know I had dry sex dry
humping on my first date with a comedian
and he came in his pants on our first
date
it rhymes with bologna I think the story
is baloney kill baloney but he admits it
he's like you're right but it's so hot
when that happens I'm always like no
it's yes and no I've told this story but
since we're at a new set yeah about how
this guy he was a soft core like porn
actor in Asia that I hooked up with on
that same
yeah I love soft guard porn you can
always see like in the silhouette their
dick and balls hanging and not in them
but he was so hot and I was like oh this
is gonna go really well he asked me out
he was really polite sweet he took me to
a really shitty steak spot but then he
did two things that I'll never forget
and I think to this day I'm scarred bye
first he said
which is like the antithesis of my
existence he says I eat to live I don't
live to eat
and I said okay big red flag like where
is the joy in your life you're just a
really unhappy person and then he we
were still both fully dressed we were
making out and then he grabbed my thigh
and he was like oh your legs and then he
nutted on my kneecap
why he was just done he could not take
and I was so disappointed because I was
like he's a soft core guy like he's
gonna never know he never stuck it in we
never got past my kneecaps and then
that's just it was so anti-climactic I
went home being like super sad I like
the idea of him saying he lives because
that's fun that's like like he'd just
slap a burrito out of her hand well
don't eat that no but you can never like
fully connect I feel like people aren't
don't eat the same way you eat yeah wait
is that a thing like why do you say that
well Todd doesn't eat Todd has like
boundaries of this food like he can he
eats like [__] but he does like stop
eating when he's full like I've never
even like imagined stopping again but I
think the the idea is that
like even if we don't eat the same thing
that you're enthusiastic about eating
you like eating like what you like
you're really enthusiastic about and
also then it's like they're not going to
be able to personally understand a big
part of your life a huge part of which
is mangoes which is basically every food
in existence because I love food that
much it is such a joy like when I sit
down and yeah it's like it and so when
he saw that I was like oh this is number
one never gonna work out but let's make
out anyways and then just you know I
would never be able to feel comfortable
or secure because it's like then imagine
you're sitting there with your partner
of like five years and you're like so
excited to eat your favorite like
grocery store sheet cake or like
something nasty it's like they're just
gonna look at you like you're just gonna
feel it like they're gonna think you're
disgusting yeah I need my dad because my
dad like
um this isn't going to be about him
nodding on my knee this is going to be
about shaking oh come on try to relate
to you no um
he like his favorite thing to do is just
like go eat bad food with me that's like
and my mom does it with him too so I do
need that with someone where it's like
like Todd and I'd be like ice cream you
know what I mean it's like you need that
yeah especially when you know there's no
sex later on that day and you can just
be really really just like move with
full abandon that doesn't stop us you
know that like gets me going more I
don't know why like a full stomach I'm
just like let's go all the way like I
want to feel
yeah as possible but I but the blood
then goes away from your genitals into
your digestive that may be true so I
just she's little don't worry his penis
goes to her digestive well you know
they're
you're actually short people are the
future they say if you mate with a short
person you're you're actually saving the
world have you read that there's no way
that's true but tell me everything I
think it was like either a Washington
Post article or a New York Times
articles that you should be procreating
with short people because
um you are kind of saving resources for
the subsequent generation that's because
I think you say like oh she doesn't say
resources though yeah I don't think
that's true she's a little taker I take
a lot of baths like I don't know if
that's true she overcompensates by
taking more no because even just on your
you have less to feed I think like
really tall my sister and I like we take
sorry that seemed crazy I was looking at
a monitor
I remember the parachute which parachute
when you were a kid and you did the
parachute and you'd all go under it and
sit under it in gym class no explain it
to me that sounds fun it's really fun
but it's also not anything it's not so
crazy it's such a like time killer
they're like all right kids let's do
this seven more times it's just you
gather around this like you have like a
um
a parachute with all the colors it looks
like the you know the Mexican fruit
stands I don't think she should know
about this yeah you're not look and
that's all you do you lift it up and
then you sit under and then you like
giggle at each other oh that's it and
then you do it a bunch of times and then
teachers are just I guess masturbating
in the corner
and do you play like duck duck goose
dude maybe I don't know it doesn't last
long I remember a lot less of my
childhood than you'd think by looking at
me he's blocked off yeah like I don't I
wish I could go there more and like live
there but I did you do the rope in gym
climb the Rope you know what it is it
was traumatic because I could never do
anything in gym class I would have
helped you I could never get up the Rope
I could never do a pull-up we would have
boosted you yeah I believe that you
weren't pulling up that much you should
have been able to pull up you ever did
the monkey bars I could never do the
monkey bars they hurt me yes I could
never do anything for all of our hands
yeah all of our hands we had raw raw it
hurts but you just did it anyways you're
not willing to have any sort of
discomfort so funny I am realizing that
about myself it's I'm TR you know what I
have a new like I'm sure you've it's
very like addicty
um or you know like recovering addicty
but like I'm trying to practice this
Mantra sit with the discomfort you're so
Dobbins is that all you listen to No
what's that remember what's his name
what's the guy's name the Rocks weren't
you talking about that once
I was like I know this guy puts like
rocks in his backpack oh David Goggins
kill your inner [__]
no that's Peter attia it's ralphing
where he walks with hikes or walks with
a background thing is what he calls it I
know it's a really weird name but we're
all things uh type of Massage
maybe it's called rocking I don't know
what it's called
this is so funny we got to get a rope
for in here but that was the most fun
I've ever had you didn't want to like
show off how strong you were to people
like we were like you wanted to like
impress people right we didn't have
ropes we had all the red trees best but
do you guys ever do that like do you
ever find yourself needing to tell
yourself like I need to sit with this
discomfort yeah my mom wrote Every paper
I've ever was supposed to hand in
because I would be like I don't want to
write it she would just do it so now I
have to teach myself like you have to
sit and do things every day of my life
yeah but I learned that really young
it's just it's it's because the
discomfort was so frequent for me that I
just had to get to know it and learn to
live with it and not treat it as such an
alien in my body
do you know what I mean lucky but it's I
know she's jealous she's like wait what
wait do we need a banana break oh yeah
should we
thank you
[Music]
wait a second do we have gossip this
week yes
okay I'm gonna pull it up
so we've been asking you guys the trash
Tuesday slug fam bloodbath gang
um
for which we might we're really
seriously having conversations about
getting our name back
so just they weren't there like 25 bad
friends and everyone's cool with it yeah
it's getting weird there's aren't there
like 35 overshare podcasts and
everyone's cool with it why did we get
this [__] out of the stick I don't know
I don't want to blame a past producer
but your cousin I haven't seen his
lawyer credentials
someone we know's cousin was our lawyer
um okay
so this is from one of our sluggies
um I got gossip got out of this is
actually similar to one that we heard
recently
I got gossip got out of an eight-year
relationship last year X got engaged
someone possibly four months into dating
them and posts outrageous things to
Instagram of them together
including him licking her toes
and then naked in bed together
hot gossip update he has now broken off
the engagement slash relationship that's
by the way so embarrassing I hope you
archive those pictures
ew do not post sexual things like that
that's so nice posting licking your toes
on Instagram I disagree what
that's all Bobby that was our brand
forever is just like obnoxious yeah but
you guys want to grow this
we were brothers yeah we were Bros I've
never seen you guys post eating each
other's feet
oh yeah it's more it's more like it was
comedic this is like a sexual oh they're
actually sexual okay but even do you
remember when like um
Stephen Randolph and Chelsea Skidmore do
that where he'd be like eating her out
no they kept posting it I was like guys
this is making all of us so
uncomfortable but they'd keep posting it
it was like a troll of sorts right
they're comedians not to say it like
wiping their mouth and there's this
sheen on his mouth where like he's
eating her out that's funny it's not
like and and it's so scandalous and
shocking
um okay I mean
immediately I I guess as an ex if I were
to see that I would feel pretty good
about myself because I'd be like how
path that's true because you know you're
getting to see their spiral like live in
action they're showing their like post
breakup downward spiral because if
you're ending with eight for eight years
and then four months later
he's like licking toes and engaged I
would think he was either on drugs or
he's having some kind of like psychotic
break or like something is happening
where he needs to feel seen in this way
and that's just you know or maybe that's
at him
I mean at her
like they're posting the pictures at her
like to be like look that's even better
for her it's like they're living their
lives for her
yeah you got to block people when you
break up with them if you're not if it's
like gonna affect you but it's so that
is you're gonna unblock them later much
easier said than done but you have it's
for yourself you have it's like if you
want to be healthy Jared freed I was
dating a guy and he was like [__]
around me you know Jared Friedrich yeah
yeah Jared freed gave me like advice and
he was like you have to block this guy
you can say to him like look you're
hurting me like if you want to be honest
like it's hurting me to be with you
and to see your stuff so I'm just going
to block you and I like wasn't ready and
he was Jared was like and he was right I
mean it was just like more months of
suffering that's absolutely correct but
yeah think about how hard it it's it's
an anxiety thing I think my therapist
ones called it it's called checking it's
like you can't help but check you're
addicted to it right but that's why you
block it because you can't check but
that's really [__] hard yeah but
that's why you have to do it
it's like pull-ups you know you just
keep trying I have a like kind of a
different question if you see someone
you know is like on drugs right like
they're posting online they're like
clearly like it's obvious they're being
erratic erratic Behavior like living
their best life quote unquote drugs
whatever are you what is your thoughts
when you see that because I actually
have two different
how close am I with this person
it could be anything I don't know but
I'm just saying like when you see that I
when I see that I'm like part of me is
like that's really sad I'm really sad
and then another part of me is like
well are they like having more fun than
me like is my life book bad yes
um no but wait is your art okay so is it
that there because I've had friends
where it's like something seems wrong
like where you're like okay this is like
not
like there's no one in the public eye
watching this going like this person's
okay
and I think a lot of times when people
are like drug addicts they think they're
pulling it off and they're not pulling
it off so is it like that where it's
like this is like you're gonna lose your
job you're not gonna or is it like
they're just openly posting partying
I don't know because I think you can
party and do drugs without being like a
drug addict yeah I don't think it's that
it's not that I know what you're saying
like and I I would say Dad
no I'm saying like
someone is doing drugs all the time and
you're just like
I I feel I find myself such drugs I
don't know I if I knew what drugs people
were on
though I would have a very different but
how do you know they're on drugs just
because they're slurring the words and
stuff like if people are slurring the
words like that shouldn't go online you
shouldn't be pushing yourself drunk you
shouldn't because yourself [__] up so
it's like they're kind of like bragging
that they're partying a lot kind of
they're showing that they're yeah like
sometimes I see people I know do that
and I'm like
is that bad but then I'm like no maybe
I'm judgmental and they're having fun
and I'm boring I don't know like what is
your opinion I do think you're boring
okay
I think that okay so the girl from
Orange is the New Black had that Taryn
did you see her like slurred she was
like yeah it's like you don't want to
like you shouldn't be like [__] up on
camera if you can avoid it I think right
like you if you want to go like party
at night or whatever but you shouldn't
be like in the daytime slurring your
words like admitting you're [__] a
married guy and all this stuff just
because
you don't look well you don't want to
like
I think social media is about like you
know you call her the girl from Orange
is the New Black I call her the girl
from Crossroads movie she's not in um
Eight Mile she's in eight miles an eight
mile wow she's got some I just couldn't
remember her she's great wait but I want
to go back to this because you do bring
up a good point you're saying like if
someone is drugged or drunk on camera or
driving like she's in her car like
there's a lot of things we're like oh
this is like if someone looks like
they're gonna die or they're gonna get
like lose their livelihood but you're
saying that's what would concern you but
someone just like bragging about being
[__] up but not actually portraying
the signs of it embarrassing people get
[__] up people party it this is like
in almost every culture people that's
what I'm asking I don't know if I'm
right or wrong I mean Kyla what is your
what are you
um it depends on how close I am with a
person and I know other inside
information if I know that he's posting
stuff but I'm also hearing through the
grapevine that he or she is you know
really starting to unravel of course
I'll check in and say [__] be like hey
you good you okay like
um but you know I lived with an addict
for a long time and Bobby always used to
tell me it's like you know there's
really not much you can do no until
you're ready so um but I do check in but
do you look at that and So you you're
saying you don't look at that like oh
they're having more fun than me no way
because I don't have fun when I'm that
[__] up I was like I'm sure in the
moment but like I'm somebody who drinks
even two drinks the night before and
that I wake up because I had such a poor
relationship with alcohol in my 20s even
now when I'm drinking moderately I still
wake up with that same dread I felt in
my 20s
so maybe Molly sometimes doing cocaine
at your wedding you're like Molly
remember when you asked who I did Molly
with yeah
um it's funny that you did ask that why
I was on
the heavy metal Cruise oh no no was it
with Papa Roach
I gave a little brother roach Molly he
OD'd he was in the infirmary
something to say little brother roach on
that trip
he was okay
they have infirmaries on cruises they
haven't like updated to modern times
with like hospitals or nurses offices
wait Esther I know this might not be
your cup of tea but I really would love
to have Papa Roach on our show wow what
do you mean why they rule they're cooler
than him and he has had enough stories
about that that's cockroach to have them
on here like I feel like if we've talked
about them at least 10 times they should
come on our show
I can get Nickelback too oh no oh my God
I would love to Chad Kroger Chad the way
Chad treated me during that meet and
greet was the way like you would have
thought I was Esther a rounded [__]
Jenner I mean I was like Chad did
Michael not die wait so you met him yeah
I did the meet and greet so I brought
Todd I shouldn't have brought Todd I
probably could have gone backstage but
he's got short hair now he they were
great they were girl deliberation where
it's like how far can I get yeah just by
myself or with a guy in tow it's so it's
just they're not gonna they don't want
to see like in Vegas I am such a rock
star when I'm by myself and then if I
bring a boy with me it's over all my
everything is just you're you're just a
peasant yes you might as well you know
what I mean just call it a day stay in
your room don't even go out because
you'll get in nowhere it no even walking
through the airport whether I'm like
with Dave or by myself the difference is
so staggering I'm like oh men like look
at me like they are worried about you
they're like where's this little kid
going where is her um where's her um
pass
are your parents here a little kid
little boy
wait okay should we do more gossip
okay wait we didn't finish the
Nickelback thing so oh yeah he wasn't
that
he get well Michael I know through when
I opened for Doug Stanhope I met him and
um he
yeah I became friends with them on
Instagram and stuff and then I saw I was
on a walk and I saw their poster and I
was like oh I gotta come
I was like I want to come backstage and
he was like okay you meet and greet I
was like okay
and so we waited in line with the
regular people
and then we were treated like regular
fans and I was like not by Michael
Michael was the best but I was like you
didn't warn them that like a really cool
comedian
very funny cute I love this shirt on you
I love it too
I'm not gonna give it to you I don't
want it okay but you can borrow it thank
you
so cute that color might be your color
like a little Chola yeah kind of ready
okay okay I'm skipping a few oh yeah
this one yeah same
um my boyfriend admitted that my BFF and
him used to sext before we even met
before me and my BFF even met okay
totally legal she still hasn't said
anything about it should I bring it up
LOL that is tricky I just feel like you
don't always have to bring it up bring
it up no because then you don't want
people to get paranoid and think
something's happening it's not happening
it's like this is over I agree like yeah
I don't think there's any reason to
bring that up to make her feel
uncomfortable
I don't know but then I guess it is
weird because it's like you know she
doesn't know that you know and maybe
she's got like a dick pic of your
boyfriend on her phone but who I mean
who cares if you guys are friends it's
like pass the joy around it's all good
yeah like I'm Eskimo sisters with
all of my girlfriends I do have to say
there is a girl
not you guys actually we don't we're not
friends she's like actually we're not
friends well no you need to need to know
um there's a girl that I'm asking my
sisters with and then she married the
guy and Inuit sisters
oh Inuit sisters what's that oh like
yeah
what are you yeah I don't think you
could say Eskimo anymore yeah I don't
like how you said I don't think
I don't know I need you to know
okay so let me say that our expert I
need you to ask him no I want crossover
lovers with all of my girlfriends when
people are cool about it nothing feels
better on this Earth when the truth is
out when you don't have to like hide and
the person doesn't care because like it
is weird when someone it's like their
current husband I like hooked up with
but it was like years and years and
years ago but when I first met her I was
like
she was already married I think I know
it was like I wasn't gonna bring it up
that's like up to him I feel like he's
that's her his yeah he did he told her
and then she was really cool about it so
she brought it up to you she was like we
have a lot to talk about I was like oh
thank God because I was like it takes
the pressure off so but see I'm in sorry
to interrupt but I am I have a exact
situation where I have a friend who I
have like had a hookup with her husband
there's no way I want that to that
sounds I don't want to there's no reason
for us to ever talk about that unless
she wants like it's there they're in a
yes it is up to them and like if he
wants to that's what I'm like whatever
your like relationship level is like and
how honest you are with each other is
like your business and I'm like but I
don't want to be in like trouble I
didn't do anything but you should never
be right but there is like but on the
flip side of that if I like met someone
that I knew that had hooked up with my
husband you'd immediately masturbate
I guess I would hope that I'm mature
enough that I'd be like
who cares I you'd be calling her dance
class oh no yeah I did okay but so you
and that girl are not BFFs though it's
weird that yeah a BFF if there it's if
it's a girl who's this close to me
wouldn't say oh [__] like that guy I
used to yeah you know what you know what
all good he's all yours like that's
that's it but you know what she's trying
to be polite and be respectful of her
relationship the best friend I feel like
so I think that our friend that did hit
us up
here are sluggy I think because your
boyfriend told you and then so that's
it's the honesty's in your relationship
I think you should go to your friend and
be like hey you know I know so there's
no like weirdness I don't think that's
necessary
okay I I think it is you do I do think
it is because I think that she's
uncomfortable there is a distance the
friend is uncomfortable
um also by the way let's suppose let's
paint this picture
um let's suppose Jenna
I've been friends with her for a decade
I was with Bobby for a decade we sort of
met around the same time right let's
suppose I find out now that they
actually had a thing before I'd be like
[__] why the [__] didn't you tell me it
would have been cool it's easy why was
it something you needed to hide from me
then then the suspicions would come
sometimes people hide so long though
that it's like it's like when you forget
someone's name but you've known them for
like six months and you can't ask so you
just call them hey dude
by the way dude bro
um okay I see what you're saying there
is a difference if it's your close
friend versus more of like acquaintance
and this is before they were even
friends so it's like it's so important
there's no need to hide it but it is
weird yeah like but I don't know my
friend
um is divorced from this woman now but
we had hooked up in the virgins when we
were like 14 but it was like we made out
it was like nothing he got brought me
mangoes and he climbed a tree for me I
was like okay what are you gonna do he
was tan but his wife I remember his wife
being like
we get it you mid out with him or
whatever and it was like
we're like we were like 33 at the time
I'm like it's been so long what is like
oh so creepy that you're still worried
about a 14 year old version of me that
made out with you I'm just like if we
were gonna be together we would have
been together it's like I'm telling you
rom-coms [__] with people's minds
because they always think like
everyone's getting back together yeah
everyone's getting back together all
this stuff yeah it's My Best Friend's
Wedding when she thought she was getting
the phone call because they were finally
gonna get back together and he actually
just called her to say will you be my
best woman right oh my God my okay so my
guy my neighbor who tried to pull that
with me more recently
like maybe like four years ago I made
out with him one Christmas and we had
always like hooked up when we were
uh
uh in like middle school and high school
and I had been looking up in middle
school I mean it doesn't mean sex all
right
um no we never had sex but like in
Middle School it was like making out it
was like but it was like the most like
like teen rom-com like Judy Bloom like
built up like biggest crush you've ever
had on someone and then we're like in a
hammock like you know and then it
happens and you're like oh my God you
know and so and like sneaking out to
smoke cigarettes in the park and just
like really like a fun little teen
romance novel that we lived he like I
can't remember how long ago it was like
four years ago it was I think it was
when we met up but he he tried to pull
the thing where he was like
oh I always thought we were gonna like
end up together
and I'm like no you just like tossed me
to the side and hooked up with a bunch
of other girls for my entire life that
I've known you you didn't like show up
when you said you were gonna show up
like no you treated me badly and then
you thought that I would be like a back
burner [__]
and um I saw him this weekend it was
funny because I told my mom I was like
oh Matt's coming to the show and she's
like he won't show up
and he did and she went oh my God I
can't believe you showed up she said in
front of his girlfriend but it was funny
I was like
like you don't get to pull that thing
now after you like didn't show up for me
all of these years you know no like if a
guy is the perfect guy for you that you
would have
hooked up with them unless you were like
growing down and giving them away to all
of your
girlfriends which I've done too okay but
similar but different
like
I've noticed like okay if you because
what you're saying has a lot of
similarities like someone a girl's
relationship with their dad like you
know if your parents are divorced and
like your dad is not showing up for you
when you're a kid but then he does
reappear later and it's like you don't
really know how to deal with that it's
probably very difficult
so there is a relationship like that in
my family
and
for so long I was like [__] this person
like they weren't there is this you
under Tamagotchi yeah this is my
tamagotch I'm speaking from the point of
view of my Tamagotchi about me always
she has been this entire show you know
that but like so I've always been like
[__] that person you know they they
abandon these other family members of
mine
But as time passes I'm like they just
didn't have like the tools and like the
like maybe it's okay to forgive I think
when you have no I think you should
always forget but I think with parental
stuff and with family things it's like
if you can fix that Bond I think that's
amazing you know and I do think that
people evolve and stuff but I feel like
with a guy it's like why would I put
myself if there's all of these people no
that's so true it's like it's like why
would I it's like I have one dad or a
stepdad you know or someone that raised
me but it's like it's like why would I
there's no ties there there's no reason
yeah
and he's not my friend but I'm like I
would never not I would never be more
than friends with him
right
what did you so you saw his girlfriend
yeah she was cool that's cool
but it was fun it was like cool to see
them but I was like yeah I mean
love incredible relationships with like
one of my best friends was someone I
dated for a couple of years and I love
him I love his wife I love their
children and I cannot like
if someone even brings it up and like
the in the in the most innocent of ways
that him and I ever hooked up it makes
me so icked out of my mind because I
just that is so dead like that is such
like a distant memory like don't ever
bring that [__] up like I just see him
in a completely different way now he
seeks me in a completely different way
so sometimes like I don't even like
looking at older pictures of us when we
were younger because we might have been
like hooking up at that time and it
makes me want to [__] vomit because
I'm like oh I know what you mean not
because they're disgusting it's just
because I'm like that's not who we are
our relationship is so much more than
that now like what were we doing why did
we even hook up like what were we
thinking no it's gross when you hook up
with like a friend and you realize that
and you realize like the platonic-ness
of it later and you're like oh it's just
like it's just like you bumped things
yeah like it's so gross oh no I have
that I have that I try to like it's like
you know when um you block out Trauma
from like your childhood I really my
brain tries to block that out completely
I don't want to remember it I don't want
to reminisce I don't want to be like
remember when we did nope don't even
bring that up that's gross and if he
were to ever bring that up with me I
would not be his friend I'd be like yo
bro like no we're not doing that but
thank God he never has he's like he's it
about too he's icked out that he ever
did anything with me he's like ew you're
like my sister like ew I'm like I know
is this the one your grandma thought
might be your brother no
really
him and I don't talk anymore which is
why we can't get a DNA confirmation
I've been trying to hunt him down
what
happened okay maybe one more thing oh
you you know what I was okay I was
thinking with my neighbor it was like
because I came to him when we were like
21 and I gave him like the like I had
like laid it out for him and I remember
saying something so it's like so
embarrassing now but it was just so like
vulnerable and I told him I was like all
of these years you've like you've hooked
up with me in between girlfriends and I
have just had boyfriends in between
hooking up with you
and I gave him like my rom-com line you
know what I mean I get and it he just
didn't take it and then it was like for
you to now like when we're grown-ups
it's like
it just wasn't gonna happen
that is I I see the picture you're
painting it's like
I liked you I wanted you you didn't want
me yeah and then you're like all of a
sudden you're like I thought we'd be
together yeah because I was always
waiting for you like a pathetic person
I'm like yeah how would we be together
like where
you know it's terrifying as terrifying
is I started seeing some guy and he
really couldn't give two shits if I if
we didn't he's like if you don't choose
me he's like it's okay I'll be fine I'll
get over it I'm like
wait Dave does that to me they're like
no because they're secure but I actually
believe him he's he's just like look
it's gonna suck but also like life goes
on it's okay because I'm always like I'm
so sorry I'm just not in a space to be
in a relationship like if you wanna and
he's like like chill out if it does you
know what you're not you're not hurting
me it's not people that are like zooming
forward to things they're just like in
the moment they're like right now we're
here it's fine
I'm trying to be dramatic you know like
oh this this is something and he's like
it's not that serious it's okay like
chill out and I'm like how dare you all
of myself anxiety about being in a
relationship Todd figured it out because
the way to do it he was just like look
if this isn't the right thing for you
then I don't want to be here either like
I have no interest in being in a
relationship that's like not good for
both of us and he said that to me like
right at the right time of our
relationship and it was like
I'm going to Vegas
um on Friday I have to be there what's
the over and under of me um randomly
getting married
oh I love this wait what are you gonna
do there I'm gonna go to show
um eat really good food
um it's my friend's 40th so it's like a
Cirque du Soleil thing
um but I'm also gonna do my own thing
um but yeah what's the over under like
are you saying wait do not want to say
but yeah I don't want to say okay
I'm singing a nice beautiful Corner
Suite really wait what are you gonna eat
um crab legs there's um there's a
steakhouse I'm also gonna maybe try best
friend yeah go to best friend oh my God
I couldn't get in there
all the Asians know each other
wait I told you that story when I was
like I was so desperate for him to
figure out who I was yeah I was like
because I knew he was going to know me
like I knew I was like there's no way he
was like I was with Ali makovsky and Ali
was we were there and um he goes I'm
like yeah you know we're comment you
know like just I keep liking it yeah I
keep throwing this out and he goes this
was during skank Festival he's like
um
he's like yeah I was like oh do you go
to The Comedy Store a lot he's like yeah
and I go who do you go to see and he's
like listening obviously says Bobby and
I go oh Bobby yeah yeah
I have a podcast with Lila and he like
didn't hear me and I was like
I was like he's gonna like I was like
it's gonna happen I was like so
desperate I was like looking at Ally
like
and then finally
um I said it again and he was like oh
I've seen oh I totally know yeah I was
like that's right wait a second we
should have him on the show
he's so freaking great he's the best
yeah the restaurant's unbelievable are
you serious I'm so mad I've never even
been there so bad wait I've never even
been to best friend I think I want to go
this weekend their merch is really good
too yeah they have a whole like front
store of merch were you allowed in that
part no
another food's so good he gave us like a
feast he brought everything out I'm
amazing oh my God no but I do love the
like there's just like a random hand
roll bar at the Cosmopolitan and I
always go there like I sit there by
myself it's like a bar it's up in their
little cafe I do love the cosmo a lot
that's like randomly your bar is
beautiful everything about it yeah
um so we don't think I'm coming back as
a wedded woman that would be fun if she
tries to beat us to marriage I feel like
I see you getting married in like Hawaii
randomly not Vegas no not nothing
Reckless because there's like you have
true possible loves in Hawaii loves yeah
I think there's some gloves
you've heard of True Loves certainly
yeah she's dated multiples you're not
wrong
um okay I mean unless you're is there
someone
that you know of that will be there that
like yeah
um there's a chance that one of my
Hawaii loves will be there at the same
time really okay well that's different
yeah get married you think so prenup
oh that's I know I can't do it yeah
prenup there have been some I'm not
gonna lie there have been some awkward
prenup conversations in my house lately
and I'm not coming from you I've been
shutting them down I mean what kind I
want to know just let's get a prenup
just like casual conversations and I'm
are you anti
yeah that's because he makes more money
than her right now
yeah I am anti because I think it's so
sad but I also fully respect it and
fully get it but okay so much like how
earlier you said it's cool to be married
multiple times
I feel like I'm past the that
opportunity like I think if I was in my
20s and you know whatever I I know I
sound delusional and I know it's like
here I am on camera saying this like I
don't see a divorce happening I don't
either I'm like I can't imagine not I
know and I and I also know that everyone
says that and then they get divorced so
it is I know that but
there's something about it and I'm so
not traditional like I don't know why
and it is probably like a prenup is more
than just the money of it all it's the
power of attorney it's someone to make
decisions on your behalf you know if
should something happen to you it's more
than just are you gonna get a print up
with kalila like power of attorney
right like how old were you when you got
your divorce
29 or we separated when I was 29.
um cute but I didn't super cute I didn't
think it was going to last so they
didn't you just were like I didn't want
to do it I was a people pleaser how long
into your relationship did you guys get
married
so we dated in college and and then I we
broke up for a while and then we got
back together so seven years total was
it like was it the feeling of like last
ditch effort at making it something like
you know not wanting to reject someone
that's an ultimate rejection right yeah
I mean I just he was like it's he put so
much thought and effort into it and I
just it was selfish but I couldn't say
no and I wanted to oh
wow that's rough that is wild and I
absolutely understand it I completely I
do too because I'm people pleasy oh my
God yes but that's why I was like to
Todd before I was ready I was like do
not [__] propose to me I was like do
not don't because you would say yes I
would say yes and then I'd be like uh
look I just wouldn't be ready he really
did play it right with you he took so
long to I was like just give me the
[__] ring like I was like about to
propose myself
ridiculous this looks like the basement
I lost my virginity in wait I love that
I know I love I love the basement the
wood panel
if there were Tommy Hilfiger shirts like
hanging on the wall like they were art
I'd be like Brad I was when zooming with
someone who was in a room that had this
this wallet and I was like I love those
walls she's like oh we just moved in
we're tearing them down immediately I
was like oh yeah it's for trash people
hello well you guys thank you so much
for joining us in our brand new wooden
set basement set
I hope you 555 a lot we had a little Co
I have like a cozy episode today to just
kind of break in the new space
right yeah we're cozy talking about our
favorite let's replace Esther
just be so desperate so for me to agree
with you
no put the back on Mr how bad is your
eyesight without
um I would get a headache wait are you
we're getting a headache you barely need
them were you a baby with glasses
because those nothing is cuter than
babies with glasses no and I'm actually
really offended that you thought that
that's no I was a very cool did you have
a helmet I was a cool baby you don't
know yeah you peeked yeah and diapers I
was very cool can I see your glasses can
we put through this
foreign
we have banana pillow as a sit-up we'll
see you next week with a brand new
episode we love you we love our new set
and our new producers they can't hear
you oh
thanks guys we love our new producers we
love our new set this place rules so do
waffles waffles roll
I know I know I say Roosevelt
bye guys
[Music]